my friend is telling me that the volcano
seems to be starting to rot if that
volcano goes up we have nowhere to go
that got my attention
so if you say scared I would say that I
got the realization that what that meant
I went called for like a fraction of a
second but that meant that just my
adrenaline started to kick in and it was
a very very strange experience because
now you have tunnel vision it's about
survival
the following is a conversation with
Natalie Cabral an astrobiologist and
scientist at The seti Institute
directing the Carl Sagan center for the
study of Life in The Universe She
explores some of the harshest places on
Earth including free diving in volcanic
Lakes all in the pursuit of
understanding living organisms beyond
Earth
for this she holds the woman's world
record for diving at altitude both scuba
and freediving
she's amazing
this is the Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's Natalie cabal
you are the director of the Carl Sagan
Center for research at The seti
Institute Saidi of course stands for
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
one of the things you do as part of that
is travel to some of Earth's most
extreme and dangerous environments in
search of organisms that live in
conditions analogous to those on Mars
first let me ask what the job posting
for the work you do looks like is it
like shackleton's ad in 1900 that said
people wanted for hazardous Journey to
the South Pole small wages a bit of cold
long months of complete darkness
constant danger and also where do I
apply
that's funny because there was not
really a job application in fact when
you're a scientist you have questions in
your mind and you have hypotheses and
you start to list the kind of thing you
need to answer
and then when you you see the kind of
thing you have to answer then you kind
of know the places where you need to go
to do that as far as science is
concerned started with analyzing data
from the Mars missions and I had written
a PhD about water on Mars first looking
at channels and the history evolution of
of water but then during my postdoc I
started to look where that water was
spawning interestingly enough everybody
was about channels and water and whether
catastrophic or whatnot or seepage but
when you are talking about pounding
water like lakes or ocean people were
studied waving their arms a little bit
so it was a little bit of a ill battle
interestingly enough yeah but that got
us on track with my husband uh we were
working together and we started
developing the idea the concept of lakes
in impact craters
so why an impact crater is just because
the Viking Mission at the time which is
what we were working with the resolution
and the topography were so poor that
there was really no way of telling where
you had a real low in the topography the
only thing you knew was a hole in the
ground was an impact crater so when you
sell valleys what was the Viking Mission
the Viking Mission landed on Mars in
1976 and there were two lenders and two
orbiters so they were really our first
fit on the ground on Mars but they were
under they were not moving they were not
going and that was the data you were
looking at it was already in the 90s but
we didn't have yet the Mars Global
surveyor and whatnot we still work for
20 years we worked on that I did my
master and my PhD thesis on bike
ignitions you mentioned that the places
you go to are defined by the questions
you want to ask
let's just step back what questions have
always tugged at your heart well that's
the thing that's why I was looking at
those images and saw some likes and then
came time where we started talking about
sending lenders and and Rovers on Mars
and looking maybe at the possibility
that Mars was habitable and lakes are
particularly good places to look for
those questions so this is how it all
ties up so you were always curious about
life out there I have been always
curious about life in the universe and
about questions on how we got to be here
and and the bigger question now with 25
years more and you know in in that
business
it's more about understanding the origin
and nature of life rather than whether
there is life or not on Mars I mean this
was really for me a stepping stone to
bigger questions but they were
definitely important because they helped
me frame
my way of thinking about this question
and so looking at Mars Alex
understanding what the conditions were
3.5 billion years ago or close to 4
billion years ago then I knew the type
of environment I needed to explore here
on Earth as analogous
to be able to understand what type of
life
still survives in those environment and
what kind of instrument and what kind of
resolution do I need
to actually detect it so this is how the
whole thing started and it started with
a small Grant literally 40K it was a
discretionary fund and this is how I got
started in my in my career and so many
of these questions you can answer by
looking at life in extreme conditions
here on Earth but let's let's step back
a little bit and look at Mars
and lakes on Mars just going back to
your PhD and before and maybe today what
do we understand about life on Mars
what do we understand about Lakes on
Mars is there water on Mars what do we
understand about the conditions from
four billion years ago on Mars well
we've gone a long way remember from from
the Viking where we had no resolution
well we'll had a little bit more
resolution with than with Mariners what
did you think at that time sorry to
interrupt it was just take us back to
that mindset it was really the
exploration like the your first look at
a planet you have to remember that the
first mission that successfully snapped
some pictures of Martha was Mariner for
and then everybody at that time was
still under the spell of you know it's
Wells and and the idea that Mars looked
with telescope so similar to the Earth
polar caps we could see them with a
telescope and we knew it had season the
actual tilt is pretty much the same as
the one for Earth so when Mariner 4 left
everybody pre not everybody but a lot of
people thought that we would see the
crystal cities and domes and stuff that
another civilization might have evolved
in parallel to us in the solar system
and of course when the first images came
back and Mars looked with that kind of
resolution it I had uh like the Moon it
was a huge disappointment then minor 9
came
and that changed everything there is
there was a little bit of drama because
Mars started the one of the biggest
storm it ever experienced and so for
three months we had an orbiters circling
around Mars and not seeing anything
but then when the dust cleared all of a
sudden we started discovering volcanoes
valleys ancient channels Dune Fields
polar caps and see what I'm talking to
you I don't need to invent any words
to describe Mars
and although the myth of
extraterrestrial civilization on Mars
was gone all of a sudden
the imagination of the scientists
started to pick up because right away we
were seeing something that was familiar
that we could describe so right away
Viking would put on The Fast Track and
the idea was so Mars looks so much like
Earth could have been although it's arid
and there is little atmosphere Etc
could there be life and of course behind
this at the time there were people like
a Klein and Sagan called Sagan uh just
you know uh thinking about how can we
test the idea of biology of Life on Mars
so this is what Viking did but of course
at the time when the two lenders arrived
on Mars
we didn't have the context of the
geology of the environment we didn't
have much data at all so the data that
Viking
send back was very confusing some people
still think today that we discovered
Life on Mars at the time because some of
the experiment turned out to show a
strange signal but most of the community
think that it can be explained by a
chemical reaction that we see today so
it was so confusing that NASA decided to
say okay if we want to be serious about
looking for Life on Mars we have to
understand the environment because life
and environment co-evolve
so as cause or effect a planet is going
to give you the physical chemical
environment for life to happen these are
the boundaries but once life is here
it's going to change everything one of
the biggest impact of life was to inject
oxygen into the atmosphere of the earth
three two billion years ago and that
changed everything including our
signature in space
so there is this coevolution so if you
want to understand one you have to
remove the other from the equation this
kind of a two unknown equation so even
though oxygen changes our signature
today
what if all life on Earth died and now
we fast forward a billion years
what would be the traces left it so the
question I'm trying to ask is
if life had existed on Mars what would
be the signs we would look for that's a
very good question the thing is that if
you draw the parallel with Earth it took
82 percent of Earth's history
geological history to go from very
simple life microbial life to complexity
and when I'm saying complexity I'm not
even talking about us I'm talking about
animals so Marcy smaller lost its
magnetic field very fast and lost its
atmosphere is very fast
life also
appeared on Earth very fast so the
condition being quite similar at that
time between the Earth and Mars it's
assumed for a moment that life appeared
on Mars it would have been Simple Life
when conditions started to degrade which
was less than a billion year after the
planet had formed so everything at the
surface
would have disappeared except maybe for
morphological traces of the interaction
between life and its environment so on
Earth the best example are what we call
stromatolites these are rock formation
that are built by microbes so we know
that we we know how to recognize them
you could have chemical traces as well
there is some interesting question marks
right now about carbon Isotopes at
Crater because we found an abundance of
C12 which normally is used by life on
Earth but it can produce be produced by
other things so it's not that it's a
real bio signature in itself but it's
intriguing we have now the C12 and we
have methane but uh going back it's a
Time on Mars 3.5 billion years ago where
you have lots of distractions where you
have lots of impact cratering Etc so but
we still have very old rocks that are
that survive from that time so these are
good uh good places that's why we're
sending the Rovers in those places
ancient lakes and impact craters and and
places where you have very old rocks So
when you say ancient lakes and impact
craters the simple question so impact
Creator is a Creator created by a giant
rock hitting the planet and yes a big
rock that can be metal or rock or it can
be a comet as well mostly eyes so is
that good for life or bad for life
it's actually both
um interestingly enough the building
blocks of life the bricks the stuff we
are made of carbon hydrogen oxygen and
nitrogen and phosphorus they were
included
on our planet they were built in just
because our planet is made of this kind
of rocks asteroids and comets coming
together by what we call a Christian so
they were built in when an asteroid
comes there is a lot of Destruction
going on but at the same time those
rocks they bring with them those bricks
of life and they create lots of energy
and if the environment around is
favorable you might possibly be have
some sitting going on that's one of the
aspect of what we call panspermia which
is the fact that comets and asteroid
have the building blocks of life and
better than them and that given
favorable condition they might be able
to see planets this is a theory what
percent of you
when you're looking up at the stars and
wondering about this stuff thinks that
past Premier has is what happened on
mars or or on Earth
which is the building blocks of life
came from elsewhere well but you know
that's the thing panspermia is a vector
potential Vector which means that it
actually distributes the stuff of life
left and right but it doesn't explain
the origin of life it does it's not the
environment itself it just promotes
maybe and we still have to prove this
but what we know is that the stuff we
are made of is very abundant all over
the place including in interstellar
medium so it's all over it's all over
the idea is that maybe it just waits to
have the proper environment and we know
what it needs here on Earth it needs
water it needs energy shelter and
nutrient so you're fundamentally
interested in the origin of life
and the big leaps
that in evolutionary history that could
be like an origin of something origin of
eucharia's origin of
photosynthesis origin of whatever I just
think if we're a civilization here on
Earth and we survive another few hundred
years
I think it would be a good idea to take
a big gun and just shoot life out there
like a lifegun basically try to create
panspermia that's a good backup solution
so one way is to actually uh copy our
brains and actual humans some complex
information and send it out there
another way to preserve life is just to
like
send the basic building blocks send them
a bacteria a bunch of
whatever the rugged organisms are on
earth just send a bunch of those these
are not the building blocks they are
actual organism so what is that a nice
shortcut or do we want to because you
said building blocks are everywhere yeah
freaks of Life the carbon hydrogen Etc
uh they they wear uh produced by the
death of precious Stars so this is how
they were produced and um stars like
arson uh started to form 10 billion
years ago that doesn't mean that the the
sun is the only kind of star that
produce you know life or an evil life
but actually was produced in uh 10
billion years ago now what you're
talking about is is a little different
right now there are many
um
many efforts to do the type of thing you
are talking about which is to put our
DNA on whatever kind of substrate and
preserve it involves either in different
place on Earth or on the moon some
people are already thinking about
putting DNA on the moon as far as brain
is concerned and it's drawing towards
transhumanism which is uh the
enhancement of who we are through Ai and
machine learning of course having
backups is a good thing for me I would
say that taking care of our planets and
going back to a place where we are in
equilibrium with our environment would
be also maybe the best backup possible
and let Evolution do its things right
now we are like teenagers with enough
brain to create Cool Tools
but we don't have enough brain to
understand yet the consequences of what
we are doing and right now we are paying
for this so uh the question is whether
we are going to be able to move
forward and learn from the mistakes we
are making to become a mature
civilization you probably heard of the
Drake equation that would be the L at
the very end the duration the duration
of intelligent civilization exactly and
and or at least uh the length of time a
civilization remains detectable it can
disappear from the radar screen
literally for a number of reasons the
first one is
destroy itself or being destroyed by
external uh events or it can become so
in tune
and with the universe and so Advanced
that it disappears because it melts
really in the background and it's not
visible anymore uh there are some wild
theories out there saying that
um civilization might be so Advanced
that you cannot distinguish them from
physical processes and uh that was an
example doesn't say that this is the
case but some people say imagine that in
fact all the dark matter that we we see
or we we theorized about is in fact some
sort of a biological uh process so you
can think about a number of things
personally I believe that
what you talk about about preserving our
information is kind of what life does we
we need to look at ourselves uh as not
different
of what the little cell that started off
was and this is what tells you not about
the origin of life but in fact the
nature of life which is a lot more
interesting to me because it is the
nature of life is really what is going
to give you some Universal signature to
look for it all over the place and not
only around ponds of water for Life as
we know it but the nature of life is
telling you that life wants to
get the most information possible around
its surroundings and complexities in
fact the ability to
gather and exchange and preserve the
most information possible and and so
what you're saying is kind of preserving
the kind of information we have
so in the things that we are doing
as life happened
and I say happen because we don't know
what life is uh we have 123 definitions
of life and some people are saying we
don't have any definition we only have
descriptions of life
and and that's true and that's true so
think about it for two minutes we are
looking for something we don't know it
is but we have a few clues about the
nature of life there are some really
good theories the first one was
Schrodinger right uh in the 40s right
now there is a guy named Jeremy England
it's another biophysical theory of life
it says life is the inevitable resolve
of thermophysics
this is the best way to beat entropy to
fight entropy but when you look at what
we are doing if you want to know what
the nature of life is look at our
languages and they can be very different
languages but they all have the same
purpose right exchange information
understand you know store information
and and uh also whether it is with
somebody at the outside
or thought in yourself
that's the same thing the cell was doing
but now when you're looking at life and
at the structure of our languages
life started with anatom so it's an atom
they get together to create inorganic
molecules then you have complex
inorganic molecules then you get to
organic molecules complex in organic
molecules and then you have RNA DNA Etc
look at the structure of our language
we created alphabets
letters
that's your anthem then we put them
together to create syllables right those
syllables get together to create words
tell you something
but they are nothing without a verb that
gives the direction that's RNA and DNA
and and then you can put all the
complements you want our languages are
built exactly as life is built we are
repeating patterns I call this the
mandelbrot universe and the fractal
Universe because this is exactly what it
is uh I I would say that as much as I do
believe to sending probes to explore the
Universe I say we should also look
inward to find the uh the answer to some
of the profound question of who we are
what's life what's the nature of life
because we are expressing life so
searching not for life
but for the nature of Life the nature of
absolutely I am more interested in that
because the day we understand the nature
of life then we have a universal
um by your signature and it doesn't
matter whether this life respond to the
same kind of biochemical processes as we
do although it makes sense I I told you
about the generational aspect of the
bricks of Life the stuff we are made of
the sun is part of the youngest
generation of stars and the first two
generations of stars didn't produce the
kind of elements we are made of they
were stars that were either
uh without metal just made of allium and
hydrogen or poor in metals
so the stars died off
and stars like the sun were born from
those and this is why we have elements
like carbon hydrogen oxygen that is
running now
um and and that's the life we're built
on so I I think it's not stupid to be
looking for something that looks like us
because right now in the universe this
is the stuff that's the most abundant
and we see with the exoplanet with
Kepler with tests and and now with gem
swipe we see that there are many many
different type of planets that may be
habitable in the habitable zone of their
stars there are countless stars like the
Sun but more interestingly enough there
are other type of stars where you do
have habitable zone as well and where
the duration of the Stars
sometimes a thousand times more than our
sun
so you can imagine all sorts of things
and you can imagine what type of life
would be on around those Stars the
biochemistry might be quite similar in
fact and especially for the simple life
because Simple Life Starts really
quickly on Earth so my take on this is
that the universe is full of
cyanobacteria but as far as intelligent
life it takes more time so that can take
different you know aspect do you think
it's possible that the universe
it's full of bacteria and even those
stars that last a thousand times longer
than the Sun
even even on the
planets that orbit those
Stars
maybe it's bacteria
and four billions and billions and
billions of years we actually don't know
what triggered the evolution to
complexity on Earth that's still a big
question mark is that the most
impressive invention on Earth to you is
that Cambrian Revolution is really what
took us towards what we are and in the
meantime there were the dinosaurs Etc
the dinosaurs were wiped out so the
evolution could have taken a completely
different turn uh it's always I would
say mass extinction that are going to
drive what's the end game but
um
yeah you take two planets and you change
you know those asteroid impacts all
those big geological events that wipe
out like 90 of Life at any time the
thing that seemed to be
um interesting there are two things the
first one is where you are located on
our galaxy uh matters a lot
we actually are in the habitable zone of
our galaxy
and if you are too close to the center
then it's a lot denser and remember we
have the Oort cloud around our solar
system and if you are in the region of
the Galaxy that's too populated then you
are going to run interaction
gravitational interaction with all these
stars and since it's more dense you will
have more of the Comets that are living
in the old Cloud being ejected from the
Oort cloud and coming towards the inner
solar system and collide with planets so
you will have more of these impacts if
you are too close to the center of the
Galaxy not to mention the radiation
there is a place in our galaxy where
it's a really bad neighborhood you don't
want to be there you wouldn't be able to
have life but what really matters is
extinctions but also
um the climate history
of a planet has a role to play and it
seems that
it's a theory it still has to be backed
up by more observation but there is a
good correlation
between not only the passage of the
solar system towards the center of the
Galaxy there is one place where we get
hit by asteroid because of the
interaction I was telling you about but
the other one is the climate with the
minankovic Cycles big jumps in life's
Evolution seem to be associated with
snowball Earth episodes
we don't know why yet
snowball episode
intuitively you would think that they
are connected to a decrease in life
because the whole earth is covered in
ice
but for some reason there were big jumps
in evolution right after
each of those episodes
and and today there are other things
like why all of a sudden you have
mutation that seems to be responsible
for you know a big jump in evolution we
are not clear yet so all of those things
when you're thinking about life
elsewhere are going to come into play
and I cannot tell you that a planet that
remains habitable for much longer than
the earth will have an evolutionary path
that's the same or different depends on
extension depends on climate depends on
but not it's a little bit surreal there
were two descendants of apes
figure out what what the heck is going
on and I mean we're very biased even as
a so you uh we're biased as humans
you're less biased as a scientist uh but
we still love Earth we still don't know
anything but this Earth and so even
though you tried to get escape from
thinking of what life is in the search
for the nature of life we still kind of
connected to the way we understand the
nature of life here on Earth so
I think that it's a little different
than that we are biased when it comes to
the origin of Life yes because
well we are the only model we know and
as I said it makes sense because it
seems that a lot of
you know uh stars like the sun appear
till billion years ago and there are
lots of words that really resemble the
Earth and lots of water out there and
lots of condition that could be a repeat
of what we know and we know that this
biochemistry works so as a again as I
mentioned what is going to change is
really the evolution of a planet
Extinction geology Etc but our model is
probably very abundant I'm not saying
that the end game is going to resemble
us because of all this extensions Etc
but this is a good bias it's one that
has the number for it you know the
principle of mediocrity I I think that
in that case it really applies where the
Earth is representative
of an abundance of other words
now of course there can be other
biochemistry we have some examples in
our own solar system Titan might be a
representative of that we are not very
clear of the kind of biochemistry that
can come out of a world where you have
hydrocarbon likes and rains and and
things like that but we are going there
so we will learn something about this so
the bias is right there the nature of
life is different
if really life is the best way the
universe has to fight entropy
there is no bias there because physics
is the same all across the universe at
least the universe we know there might
be other universes but the one we know
works with the same physics so if life
is the the best way to fight entropy
you can imagine life permeates
the entire universe and then the
question might change to like flavors of
ice cream what are the flavors of
complexity that this process this nature
of Life leads to and there we might have
bias about what complexity looks like
what beautiful complexity looks like
we'll look at humans that operate a
certain physical scale and uh time scale
and we think this is intelligence we
have another problem we don't know what
life is we don't know what intelligence
is and we don't know what Consciousness
is but we are trying to tackle the big
question but do you know what complexity
is also you know no I I think that we
have to be honest and as a scientist and
I'm going to step back and talk about
intelligence for me bacteria that has
survived like cyanobacteria
that has survived just like us
4 billion years in one Incarnation or
another and actually they are very
similar to the one that they wear 3.5
billion years ago it has some
intelligence about its environment
so for complexity it might be
that we need to take the world literally
which is an assemblage or additional
capacity to gather collect store
information maybe this is something like
that or actually use that information to
do something with it
but I do completely agree with you when
you talk about flavor of ice cream I
think this is exactly it and
I have a basic education about what
physics is doing right now
and I'm look at quantum physics and what
it says about the universe and about the
connection about an atom here and
another hair a photon here in the Forum
there and I am starting to put Maybe
wrongfully two and two together but in
my mind
and of course it's nothing until I can
prove it but in my mind the universe is
connected everywhere in all different
places so this life connection is
something that as you said pyramid the
universe and the way to find life
might be very different than to look for
the origins of life I think it's a good
thing to go out there and look for the
original glass somewhere else because
it's the manifestation of the nature of
life that's all of a sudden becomes
apparent evident to our eye but
what I think
would be our greatest achievement is
that if we can find that process of life
because at that point in my mind the
universal is sudden is going to
illuminate itself with actually
it's living Force what I can only call a
living Force to me this is what we are
looking at a universe that becomes more
and more complex with time more and more
able to gather information and
interestingly enough why
to understand itself so Sagan was right
when he was selling we are the universe
trying to understand itself and the more
we go the more the universe become alive
may be intelligent and maybe also
conscious conscious self-aware exactly
through us it does make me a little bit
sad as a human
just watching all the breakthroughs on
artificial intelligence side when
applied to Natural Sciences now more and
more to physics that the creatures that
will solve
the question of the origin of the nature
of life or just the process
the nature of life will be AI systems it
makes me a bit sad to I don't think so
uh because you think humans will at this
point in time remember who was behind AI
you know I I'm not buying in the
singularity thing yet
um
to AI is not aware AI is being built by
humans so so
um AI is a tool an extremely smart tool
as long as we build it and as long as we
use it as a tool it remains a tool and I
think there is a lot of brouhaha and of
course science fiction and movies they
don't help see I got to push back a
little bit yes I agree with you for the
most part in terms of boo haha and
sci-fi
but there is like in the work of Deep
Mind we can look at chess so we can look
at protein folding
so chess is a simple one to First Look
at
what uh Alpha zero or which is their
game playing engine
was able to discover in our stockfish
about Chess humbles the best human
players not just is better than them
it comes up with ideas that the humans
don't understand and so the AI now is
telling you uh even though it's
programmed by humans the AI is saying
like
sacrificing a pawn here is a good idea
sacrificing a queen or a bishop here's a
good idea and then you start to kind of
Intuit as a human why but you don't
deeply understand and you can say that
AI is not conscious it doesn't deeply
understand the way humans do but there's
still a wisdom and a depth of knowledge
in that chess playing program that
humans don't have and the same with the
alpha fold with protein folding there's
a and now they're applying it to physics
to simulating nuclear reactions and so
on it feels like there might be a way to
understand the nature of life
that we can kind of Intuit poetically as
humans but the the true understanding
will come from a system that's much more
computational sophisticated again you
know I would push back and my turn
because I still think that you men give
themselves ability
to do that by building that tool so the
idea that the tool you know we are
getting into the Carter shift scale and
and the Dark Forest and all these things
we can see the world this way uh at this
point in time for me
I still see
a great tool
now uh whether the Sci-Fi scenario is
going to you know uh happen Etc I still
think that we are far away from from
this but if that tool is capable of
giving me A New Perspective uh it's just
that we are starting to jump into a
deeper uh cognition of of what the
universe is whether it's through our
brain or through a different way of
gathering information remember this is
what we do yeah human variables actually
build tools and then like integrate them
enter their way of thinking maybe
another generation has to be born that
is raised with those tools but we seem
to like
take for granted all the cool
Technologies you integrate into your way
of thinking a lot of people are growing
up now their mind is integrated with the
internet
you basically reconfigure the way you
memorize things you no longer have to
memorize a lot of facts because you can
look them up really quickly yeah and so
like uh so you uh reallocate a lot of
resources for uh thinking versus memory
of just strict facts that kind of stuff
and we integrate all of that yeah and
you know there I would completely agree
with you in fact I wrote about this
again uh um in this new book that's
coming out when is the book coming out
in January it's it will be in French
actually uh to start with you wrote it
in French actually I wrote it first in
English yes and I translated into French
so the the English version is already
pretty much ready to go uh if we found a
publisher in uh in the US but anyways
um the point uh being here that I looked
at this as a relationship with
technology
as a complete change to me this is the
singularity more than anything else
which is the co-evolution of human with
technology not anymore with their
environment while we are messing up the
environment right now why we don't
respond to pandemic the way we should
because we are disconnected to the
environment we are taking our
information from and we were adapting
from right now exactly as you said we
take the information from the web from
the phones Etc we have no filter over
that information
before you were out in the environment
the information you get is the one the
planets is sending you now this
information is coming from different way
you have no way of knowing and
information is correct or not yeah I
gotta push back on that no you look at
this as a nickel system and it explains
a lot about Behavior see I like the you
said teenagers so we the technology I
think when we move past the teenager
stage enriches our ability to sense the
Earth to understand what's going on with
the environment it's just that we're
very so it's not that technology
disconnects us from the environment it
gives us more tools with which to
understand what's going on with the
environment that's true for the people
who are building the tools and know how
to use it take those tools now put them
in the general public with no filter
which is happening with social media
which is happening with a lot of things
and you see the disaster this is
creating and it's not the disaster it is
challenges you sound like a parent
talking about a teenager yes did you
it's it's The Growing Pains of a
civilization that is becoming deeply
connected
with our we can communicate all across
the world even through the pandemic the
good thing about technology this is also
something I wrote It's not the tools we
create that are bad it's the way we use
them yes and we're learning well this is
the cool thing and we hopefully we'll do
all their learning before it's too late
because our response to what's going on
in the environment our response to
pandemics is deeply connected to this
disconnect we have with nature anyways
we all agree that we are in growing
pains and hopefully we can move forward
because there is a fantastic Universe
something absolutely magical around us
and I'm talking as a scientist I mean
there is Magic not in sense of you know
trickery but in sense of wonder around
us and there are so many signs where we
are getting so close
to Revolutions in cosmology in
astrobiology in astronomy which I think
to me this is where the hope lies and
also an Awakening of understanding that
we need to be in equilibrium with a
planet if we want to move forward
because even though we have these Big
Dreams of going on Mars and the moon and
listen I am a planetary geologist so I
am all for exploration right now the
moon or Mars is not going to save your
butt because for the logistics will
still depend very much on the earth and
for a long time I think this
time we are living in
will be remembered as a
pivot
in our history for for a number of
reasons uh a time where there is a
growing Consciousness where we are
creating tools that are going a little
bit ahead of us that we have some some
difficult time to catching up uh on with
where we have to deal with the
population that's way uh too big for the
planet we have we need to really learn a
sense of balance and and a maturity as a
civilization so how is this going to
unfold right now I have no clue I draw a
lot of optimism from the similar things
that happened
and many decades ago when nuclear
weapons were developed
boy was that at the time even more
terrifying you just now created weapons
that could destroy the entirety of life
on Earth or not entirety but a lot of it
and we somehow found a balance
and the threat constantly is out there
and that threat has been made more
visceral in recent times
because the war in Ukraine
but we find a balance somehow so I have
a threat of optimism for human
civilization that we that we figure it
out we're clever teenagers I think we
are clever teenagers there is definitely
a threat of optimism but I think it's
thin
is sin because something that has
changed as well
is the mentality of of humans
um although the threat was terrifying
when uh nuclear weapons were were
created
um there was a sense of
limits you were willing to push in the
threats
um there were there was a sense of
decency
of moral values it was not perfect but
it was at least a time where people
could come together from very different
perspective and agree that something was
more important than destroying
everything but that's so hilarious you
say that yes you're talking about a
small Slither of humans which is the
scientists in the Manhattan Project
perhaps no absolutely that was also the
time when over a hundred million people
were tortured or murdered no no I agree
with that in Europe absolutely
absolutely I'm not talking about
scientists here actually I'm talking
about politicians we've gone beyond that
point now this is what I'm worried about
I mean
torture Etc unfortunately well we are
Apes exactly what you said so I think
that you know there is a lot to be not
not to blame Grandpa for that but
because we can always get better Grandpa
was a wild man
but we have to improve a lot on that
side before we can claim that we are a
mature civilization when you uh just
because you mentioned the magic uh when
you look out there
perhaps this is not a scientific
question but
you don't have to be scientific all the
time yeah well this you said magic so
there's a there's a magic to Magic that
is in part scientific and in part
I don't know whatever whatever fills us
with all as humans when we look up at
the stars do you think
the universe is full of life or not like
you know when you're sitting drinking
some wine looking up at the stars and
and wandering as a human uh do you think
we're alone or do you think
it's life is everywhere I am going to
make such an unmagical response to that
my response is that's the scientific
response yeah that if we are alone
then the universe is a statistical
absurdity
yeah and and I have no doubt in my mind
and that is an unscientific response as
well but I have no doubt in my mind that
the universe is steaming with life
what if
it keeps dying
this is what life does
but unfortunately so so the
so me that Extinction is as a process as
a part of the process of Life Extinction
seems to be a fundamental both negative
and positive component
uh so what if all the complex life out
there just keeps dying and not making a
way for like we're actually uh
statistical anomaly in us being able to
survive that l in the Drake equation
being able to survive long enough to
form complex organisms of the kind like
mammals are things with brains things
Ellie's not about that L is about how
long a civilization is capable of being
detectable which means that rich
Technologies and you know being
detectable okay so there's a more
nuanced things to L because you can have
intelligent civilizations that are not
very detectable yeah we had civilization
for thousands of years we started to be
detectable 150 years ago
so it's about technology technology that
we can actually capture from from space
you become visible to your neighbors uh
and and this is all about the Fermi
Paradox right it takes time obviously if
we're taking again ourselves as a model
but this is the only one we have
um to get to the point where we become
detectable but look at the age of the
universe even if life as we understand
it not not saying even as we know it but
as we can understand it started 10
billion years ago and it takes four
billion years to get to uh the point
where it becomes detectable that means
that the first planet where those
civilizations started off starting to be
depictable when we were still
cyanobacteria in ponds so they were you
know throwing messages and that were
passing above our heads at that point
and those civilization when you look at
them now close to 10 billion years after
the start so their son would be dead
okay in the best case scenario they move
somewhere else and what that means is
that Civilization are going to rise die
or move and transform themselves we can
see ourselves changing we know that
humans are still changing as a species
the human being in in a thousand or even
500 years from now might not be looking
a lot like we are doing uh right now who
knows where where we will be will might
be migrating into our planetary system
we might be migrating somewhere else
well you said migrating but it seems
when you look at life it doesn't
necessarily migrate it it expands so
it's not
or
place a or or place B is place a and
plays B it
could be we are talking about the human
civilization here so there are different
factors if you are a cyanobacteria or
any type of even a mammal that doesn't
have the technology to escape
the planet we were born on then it's
plan a it is right there you know
whatever happens to your planet you are
tied to it you cannot Escape it for a
human it's a little different yeah it's
a and b or whatever you know we can so
we have to expect that a number of the
civilization
extraterrestrial civilization that might
be technologically advanced a number of
them will have disappeared just because
they run the course of their evolution
or because their son run out of fuel and
they didn't have a way to escape or they
were wiped out by any kind of event and
then they will there will be those that
survive everything I've seen from life
it seems obvious that there's life
everywhere out there
in fact
maybe I don't understand the jump from
bacteria enough
but it seems obvious that there's
intelligent civilizations out there
now I don't know what intelligence how
to define intelligence but there's
beautiful complexity like when you look
at a I've looked at enough cellular
automata which is a very primitive
mathematical
construction that when you run
complexity emerges I've looked at that
enough to know that it just seems like
there's complexity everywhere out there
so I that's why I'm deeply puzzled by
the the Fermi Paradox it makes no sense
to me I mean uh that have trivial
answers to it why haven't aliens at
scale not shown up
I think the the two possible options for
me is either we're too dumb to see it
they're already here they've been
talking to us through processes we just
don't understand like like what we
experience as a life here on Earth is
actually they're everywhere conscious
aliens could be consciousness
that when we feel love for one another
that could be aliens when we I don't
know or feel fear or whatever that could
be aliens I have to agree with you none
of this is scientifically provable right
now we talked a little bit already about
that
but I would say that I
do not adhere to the Fermi Paradox
because it's very entreprene morphic
it's you know it's an interesting
exercise let's put it that way but it's
a typical example of seeing the universe
through our own eyes and this is what
the limitation is
understanding what's going on with
complexity as you said and looking at
the biophysical model and theories for
the nature of life I would agree that
probably
this extraterrestrial message is all
around us we're not yet capable of
picking it up
but I think unfortunately even though
that makes me sad the way to pick it up
is by studying life here on Earth doing
some of the science you're doing better
understand the nature of life until you
realize
uh holy crap the thing I was looking for
all along has been has been here all
along right well you know a good example
of that and it doesn't need to be
an extraterrestrial civilization look at
something that I really you know whether
or not is real I don't care because in
terms of intellectual exercise I think
it's fantastic look at the shadow
biosphere
the idea that life didn't appear
only once on Earth but there were many
different Pathways of it and
today we know when we study
the tree of life that led to us
from Luca to us
and
the shadow biosphere is telling us that
there is
or there are other pathways
that came up at the time where life
originated but they are so different
that we cannot recognize them
as being living
and we cannot pick them up in our test
because our tests are being built to
recognize Life as we know it and for me
again I don't know if this Theory
will be verified or it would be
discredited but what I like about it is
that it forces me to think on how do I
look for life I don't know
so that starts here on our planet not
even with little green man uh it starts
with very simple life that be can be so
different
that it might be just right in front of
our nose and we don't see it so that
probably starts with the the scientific
humility of always
realizing that
we might be too biased in understanding
of what is the phenomena we're trying to
study yeah I don't like the term bias
because it involves some moral
connotation that you know
in terms of scientific pathway
intellectual framework definitely what
do you think about the
UFO sightings so the widespread
experiences that people have and seeing
different phenomena that they sort of
that are mysterious that people project
ideas about whether it's aliens or not
but they can't explain it and there's
pictures and data and then the
government is involved in releasing
footage and all that kind of stuff and
that seems to Captivate the public it
always imagine it always do I mean you
know there are a number of things that
uh Captivate people especially children
actually dinosaurs and aliens still a
child yeah we are also child at heart
and so about UFOs I am a Scientist and
I'm a citizen so I'm going to tell you a
couple of things first I don't mind
talking about that at all because I
think as a scientist this is extremely
interesting because the thing I don't
know I want to learn about it this is
more knowledge so we all know the
statistics about UFOs 95 of them are
just natural phenom feminine or things
that are being misinterpreted we know
that then you have the two percent that
might be secret programs by whatever
government it's out there
another person say is about natural
phenomenon that
we don't know about yet that we cannot
explain and then there is this tiny
percentage that don't fall into all
these categories of thing and I think
that the re the report about the uaps
falls into the same kind of scheme
except that now they have at least some
patterns of speed of other things that
were in the report today we don't know
if these sightings are
part of military program or actual UFOs
I always run into that question because
of course as the Director of the car
second Center at the study Institute I
received a number of emails about the
subject people actually
confused about what the study Institute
is we are not studying UFOs we are
studying we are actually looking for
messages the way I put it you know
usually is that we are studying
extraterrestrial in their natural
habitat yes and and the UFO people are
trying to understand whether they
invaded our aerial space yes so this is
very two very different things and
unfortunately over the years I actually
respect very much people who are trying
to go to the bottom of what UFO are
following some very
scientific ways of doing this they are
very very credible agencies doing this
unfortunately there is a folklore around
UFOs and this has been a huge disservice
to the scientific community and this is
why you have been having that much
pushback for a long time by the
scientific Community because no
Congressman in the world wants to tell
their taxpayer that they are supporting
something that looking for flying
saucers and you know when you see what's
happening it's terrifying and I am
actually
concerned you know about that
relationship that people do between
folklore and real search for
extraterrestrial intelligence
in fact it's been so bad that
until today
there is no government agency that is
actually funding the city search it is a
private funded endeavor
what NASA funds right now which is a
progress is a search for techno
signature which means that when you are
looking at the atmosphere of a planet
you look for some disequilibrium that
could tell you that something is there
but it's not going to found a an
Institute or whatnot that is looking for
messages or or other things like that
does that just have to do with the taboo
associated with the folklores yes and I
think there was a pushback
from the political Arena
decades ago about that at the time where
all the Flying Saucer were coming out
and then the city Institute got it
started so but now there is more of a
willingness to look at the UAP uh Uso
phenomenon from a scientific standpoint
so much so that the government is
actually seeking some help from a
scientific institution and there are
programs to start looking into those
phenomenon and as a scientist I am
interested what I'm not interested in
again Carl Sagan comes back here I don't
want to believe I want to know and so to
know you have to have a real experiment
you have to have observation and you
have uh things that are done the right
way I don't want to have somebody that
start with what if as a question and
then turns this what if in to the only
argument and the only conclusion there
is you understand but still I think it's
valuable to appreciate the mystery and
not deny the mystery so no the mystery
is there but what I don't want is people
taking advantage of the public and
making money out of folklore well let me
flip that I understand but so there's a
folklore and like the stuff I do Ai and
Robotics for example there's a clear
fear Terminator and movies and all those
kind of stuff you could say that I'm
very concerned about this miscalibrated
uh understanding of the public of what
robots role are in society or you could
see it as a let's use a metaphor of a
wave you can say this giant wave
they'll call folklore is a really bad
idea we need to uh avoid it we need to
hide we need to build dams or you can be
a surfer and ride the wave as a
scientist
to me the fact that people are wondering
about the mystery of UFOs it means
they're wondering no they are but the
thing I I will stop surfing that wave
when it comes back to bite an entire
scientific discipline that's the science
sure for now the past 60 years
we were not able to raise money from the
government no grants it's a discipline
that has no postdoc of very little
postdoc
just because there is a fear of that
folklore on the political Arena people
don't want to be associated with that
because they confuse the two so I
stopped
there and as the Director of the Carl
Sagan Center I am just very happy to see
now that there is a course correction
in the government seeking scientific
investigators for this kind of issues
and hopefully that will write the ship
there I love it I love to see it but I
want and I love her a little
disagreements I'm I'm doing so obviously
respectfully with love and it's it makes
it for a fun conversation but I think
you know just like with surfing a wave
there there's some level of if the more
you resist it the worse it is so I we
didn't resist it yes it didn't come from
us and we paid the price
I just think that
the role of a scientist in part in the
21st century when we talked about social
media it's to direct this sense of
wonder that people have
into a direction of the rigors of
science I think we do that pretty well I
would disagree I don't think Society
does much better but there's other
places in science where the sexual life
is fair it's fairly easy place to you
know draw The Wonder of people yes
because it's a profound question that
pretty much everybody has but I think I
just want to highlight the fact that I
think a lot of scientists my colleagues
friends think that all you need to do is
science
all you need to do is this the the
scientific process the peer review
process the the data and so on but I
think communication is actually a
fundamental part of the process
um because it has to do with funding but
also has to do like where where a bunch
of humans trying to ask big questions
trying to figure this whole puzzle out
and nobody agree we do have more Public
Presentation at The Institute than
peer-reviewed articles and believe me we
have a lot of peer-reviewed Articles so
our scientists are out there and they
are sharing The Wonder of discoveries
and it's so easy these days I mean there
is not one day tell me about writing a
book right now about the search for life
in the universe I mean it's almost every
single day I had to correct something in
the chapters I was writing so study in
terms of both signatures and signals is
a pretty active field so it's getting
better right now uh it's getting better
but remember that the city Institute is
not only about the search for experience
is your intelligence this is the root of
the historical route of the Institute
but it's about 10 percent of what we do
in fact we are searching for life in the
universe from the origins of life to
extraterrestrial intelligence so ninety
percent of everything else is exoplanet
uh for instance we have a good chunk of
the capital team that is actually with
the study Institute and they are working
with tests right now some already have
some time on the gems web we have
astrobiologists we have astronomers and
those are looking for data for signals
for planets out there go outside of
ourselves and yeah go to analog places
to try and understand the type of life
that survive in planetary type
environments I mean people are always
surprised when I tell them you know
whatever flies in the solar system as
one or will be flying
we are involved so this is not something
that pops in everybody's mind when they
are thinking about the the sari
Institute because we started off as the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
but the Institute has really blown into
the search for Life along the Drake
equation all the terms of the Drake
equation just to clarify Because by the
way you're saying a bunch of terms
sometimes it's good to return to the
basics when you're saying whatever's
flown
seti is a part of the things that are
flown so we because we're using we
elusive sometimes it's that we humans
and sometimes we study yeah so the
studies is really broadly involved a lot
of the fingertips reaching out there
towards the stuff think about Mars
involved in landing site selection in
instruments that are actually on board
some of the mission in science teams for
instance uh Cassini uh New Horizon also
missions that will be coming it's the
search for life we do this all across
the Drake equation so uh studies part of
it and it's a root and it's expanding a
little bit right now we hope it will
continue to expand so this is this is a
good time uh for the Institute and it
also uh in my mind was the very first
astrobiology Institute because we have
this multi disciplinary approach where I
can bring many of these scientists from
different domains and disciplines to
think about the question and as you know
discoveries happen at the Nexus of
disciplines and it's really a privilege
when when you are in an Institute like
that
you've dived in volcanic Lakes at high
altitudes to study the creatures within
can you tell me the technical the fun
the human story of that effort the the
image that is associated with the
scientist is the person with the white
coat in the lab
in fact
um a number of us at Institute are
athletes doing extremes what would be
considered extreme stuff uh uh and not I
mean it's fun it's a little dangerous
too but it's to get data and more
knowledge so there are so many stories I
don't even know it was the first time
you did a dangerous thing with a volcano
oh so the the first one Associated to uh
the search for Life understanding was in
2002 uh where I started climbing those
High volcanoes in the Andes that are 20
000 Footers The View out there is just
beautiful you get
I is so hilarious at spending almost no
time on some epic things I love this
okay with this volcano okay how tall
these volcanoes what are you doing with
the volcano what's required to prepare
for that what does a mission look like
that look like I mean how do I mean that
is true that this is science embodied
it's like Athletics and it's science and
you're studying the extreme conditions
of life on Earth extreme beauty of life
on Earth in those conditions so what
what was what was them what are we
talking about with this volcano what how
big is it remember when we were talking
about how do I understand how I search
for Life on Mars this is how it started
for me and then I looked at environment
in my head started you know going
through the environment on Earth that
would be good analysis and then you only
have a few and the Andes in that case
are some of the best in the world just
because of the aridity of the place and
the higher you go
the least atmosphere you have the more
UV radiation you have and the Andes are
volcanic hydrothermal plus you have the
climate change that's coming you have
evaporation
it's a picture of Mars 3.5 billion years
ago and so now you are actually entering
a time machine basically
so
um remember I'm a diver
and the first time I got in 2002 to the
places uh we wanted to explore
all of a sudden I was standing at 14 000
foot looking at twenty thousand feet and
saying okay
well I need to get up there
are you scared no no because we are
prepared and the only thing I didn't
know is if I was going to be able to
make it to the top because now you're
dealing with high altitude you can deal
with high altitude sickness you can deal
with a number of thing and for God's
sake these are volcanoes and they are
dorm and they are not extinct that can
buy to buy toast a couple of times what
was your preparation for that kind of I
mean this is there is a lot of uh you
know hiking and trekking and I altitude
around here but not so high because we
don't have anything closer to those
elevations around here in the U.S but in
in volcanic environment climbing
volcanoes here we have plenty of those
diving as well I am a free diver so this
is where it's going to be hilarious
because I started with a completely
rational fear of pressurized vessels
that comes from an incident in my
childhood and so I became a freediver to
avoid having to carry oxygen tanks on my
back free diving is diving without
without anything just your lungs right
that was that started from childhood
yeah no it was to the point where when I
I saw a pressure vessel like a metal
tanks or anything I would be you know
going around and put a lot of distance
between me and that tank so I was not
going to carry any oxygen tank
um and in the first time I actually died
at the summit of that like was free
diving people look at me like I'm nuts
well maybe I am a little bit people that
work with you as well I mean that that
kind of seems kind of nuts no uh we deal
with the risk actually it's a lot of
less of a risk than uh getting with
conventional air and I can explain that
but uh ultimately what decided me to
certify Scuba
and go over my fear was that as a
scientist I needed more time at the
bottom of the lake to sample you know
rationally take my time to think and
I can stay quite long enough
as a free diver and the water
but the last thing you want to do at
twenty thousand feet is to come up at
the surface with empty lungs because
there is not much you can breathe out
there to replenish your oxygen so
definitely your time in the water is cut
short just for safety and I realized
that it was not a good trade-off for me
at some point so I I certified scuba and
after three years of exploring that Lake
free diving we finally came up with a
full scuba diving Expedition but we were
diving with rebreathers which means that
we dived with pure oxygen
so Rivers give you a bag
with stuff that looks like cat leaders
in it which is basically to absorb the
CO2 uh that you are expelling when
you're breathing and their recycling
oxygen this way so basically you are
rebreathing your own
respiration wow yeah how long can you do
that so what's what's the what's
interesting about the technology so it's
very interesting because then that
completely avoids the potential issues
you may have with the binds when you are
diving the risk of bubbles uh trapped in
your lungs because of different
pressures and different gases oh so
there's there's a complexity to the flow
of oxygen
underwater when you are breathing
regular air when you are scuba diving
here you know that you have to do some
uh different when you're coming back
when you are diving deep and you have
conventional air then you need to stop
so that you can equalize the gases in
your lungs if you come back too fast
then you can have air bubbles stuck and
then you can raise the binds which you
can wish to be paralyzed you can reach a
number of nasty issues and we want it
absolutely to avoid that so diving with
pure oxygen avoids this completely
and it has a another uh benefit and I
altitude is that well
the greater risk when you are at high
altitude is altitude sickness what is
altitude sickness is just you not having
enough oxygen in your blood so these you
know this was a good benefit it was a
good trade-off we were lucky enough to
be also trained by the military so we
came up with not the civilian rebreather
which is the big thing on on the back
that you carry on your back we actually
uh we're given Navy Seals Commando
rebrievers you worked with Navy Seals
for this the director of military
operations yes we were trained we were
trained like astronauts for three months
I spend more time I had a joke that if
somebody wanted to reach me they better
put a phone line at the bottom of the
swimming pool because this is where I
was so we trained and we trained and our
manual about the safety was about that
thick
so it was a real operation
that was three years into into it
because when you are free diving in the
Years prior there is no risk you don't
have any other gas in your lung that
what you're breathing the only Rises
come short of air and then you're in
trouble which happened to me uh one time
seriously so tell me about that time I
got to ask you about free diving before
we return to the rebreathers well all
these legs I had altitude they are
called they are at the minimum
temperature that you can have on bodies
of water uh clear bodies of water which
is for degree C it's very very cold and
so you can take a nice bath yeah
so you cannot
um
just dive with a wetsuit
so the idea was to take a dry suit and I
learned how to free dive with a dry suit
which is really the worst thing you can
do what's a wetsuit what's address so a
dry suit a wetsuit is usually what you
use in the ocean when it's not too cold
you can use also dry suit but the
wetsuit basically is going to keep you
warm because water is getting into the
suit and at the contact of your skin is
getting to body temperature and so for a
while you can you know dive like that
and need in the ocean here that's fine
that that that's fine the dry suit is
the opposite it's completely closed
which means that you don't have any
contact with the water outside and you
keep your warmth through your body
temperature and even clothing that you
can put into it so this dry suit they
are used by either go really deep in
very cold water and need to stay a long
time underwater so what's the bad part
the bad part is that
when you have those uh dry suit
you have a lot of air that can be
trapped in it usually we do what we call
burping the suit it's not very pleasant
expression but you get in the water and
as soon as you get in the water you can
see the air pockets all over the place
right so you burp the suit you open the
valve and the air comes out once you
have done that then you look with your
lead belt and and you know when you're
ready to go down and so what happened
that day is that I actually did verb the
suit but didn't realize that worked it
completely and so I went down
and immediately I felt an air pocket
going to my legs so basically air was
trapped in the suit and went on my legs
as I was diving like that and so I
didn't pay too much attention to that
because you're diving down yeah I was
driving down and so didn't pay too much
attention about that as I was you know
busy at just an awkward position but
um then I wanted to turn and go up
well no can do I was just like a buoy
and I was like that so uh the first time
I say okay I tried a second time and the
third time and by the fourth time I kind
of realized I was in trouble and the
fifth time I say okay now you better
give it your best try otherwise it's
gonna be big trouble
um and you're this is free diving I was
free diving and then you can and I
cannot what are you feeling I mean is
there a panic or no there is no panic
because you can't you cannot afford to
be panicking in fact you are always
thinking because there is training this
is the best part about training your
training allows you that space to keep
you cool
and and compose which you need to be in
that kind of situation and so finally
after the fifth time I was able to
rectify the position and get myself up
but when I got up my lungs were empty I
had been in the water for quite some
time
and I of I knew what was going to happen
so I decided to just be the plank you
know not move and don't do anything just
open my mouth and try to suck oxygen but
obviously oxygen at six thousand meters
20 000 feet there is not that much it's
about a little it's a 48 of what you
breathe at sea level
so although it was noon at that time
the skies that pretty dark and starry
oh my God yes
uh the funny thing was and that's the
first time you've experienced that kind
of uh I mean do you can you possibly
train for that like because can you also
pass out oh you could I mean the fact
that I was already seeing dark was a
real sign that my brain was starved of
oxygen and I had one of my uh friends or
colleagues on the on the shore just
telling me because I'd been under for a
little while and say is everything okay
and I I remember trying to say something
and and I was just like
oh that's I think the best lie I ever
ever I get the thumbs up you were lying
to the friend and maybe to yourself uh
no uh because I knew I was going to be
okay but it took me to be still just for
a few minutes
well can you talk about free diving I
mean what's the technical skill involved
here it just seems um
it seems exceptionally difficult like
for most people that swim you go
underwater it's it's hard so what what's
the skill there you know I think
you probably can get good or better at
freediving by training so you have
different techniques uh you can train in
swimming pool and you can say you know
frankly for me
um I go at the bottom of the swimming
pool and I sit there and then you have
relaxation uh techniques some people
meditate I can't I am not a good person
that can meditate or if I do I don't
know about it and but um my way of doing
things and and taking my mind off the
situation I'm in is by singing my head I
I love music or hearing music and in
fact knowing the kind of song I'm
singing I know about the length of time
that I'm staying on the water as well so
this is how you know so this is my own
way people have different ways what kind
of music are we talking about all sorts
of Music can be classical can be pop
music and you know just songs when you
really know that you are relaxed
and something I experience actually at
20 000 feet which was the greatest
experience of my life uh in those in
those terms is when you forget that you
have water around you at that point uh
you cannot tell whether you are the
water or water is you there is actually
no separation anymore and I felt that uh
when I was training in a swimming pool I
never could have imagined that I would
feel that way once on top of that
volcano and it happened and it was
absolutely amazing it was you know we
were talking about how life
Consciousness permeates the universe at
that point in time on that volcano that
day
it took me by surprise I was not
expecting it everything around me the
lake was
Arctic blue with all the ray of the Suns
you can
you could tell them apart every single
one of them I was surrounded by Golden
darts
and it was the most incredible
experience and I don't know if it's that
kind of environment that led me to just
you know go into whatever state of
meditation or whatnot but all of a
sudden
there was no separation anymore between
me the water the volcano and if I came
with questions they didn't matter
anymore because for that fraction of a
second it seemed that I had all the
answers of the in the universe was it
the connectedness with everything you
can call it that way I still don't know
what it means you know literally but it
is
a moment where you feel that it doesn't
matter it really doesn't matter anymore
it was a absolutely absolute peace
absolute understanding and it was
incredible it was an absolute uh
awareness could you describe it as
beautiful
that could go beyond that I think that
there is clearly in my mind today no
words that can express how perfect this
was it does that start to speak to why
you love diving or is there something
special about that place
diving at such elevations and volcanoes
you know I started diving pretty much
this is the first thing I did when I was
near water in fact there is a very fun
little incident with my parents me being
on the shore of the lake on vacation I
was
three years old maybe and I had this
little Life Savers you know on my arms
and my parents were not watching and in
my little brain I still can't remember
today saying well
nothing bad can happen to me I cannot
drown if I go underwater see that's the
logic of a three-year-old yes yeah it
kind of works I mean that's yeah well
pretty brilliant so I removed
the Lifesavers that I had and I just
went in the water my mom said before she
could do anything I was under and it was
like a natural thing and for me I felt
immediately at home and and you know as
little as I was completely and it goes
beyond that and you know this sense of
connectiveness or Oneness or whatever I
always felt
good and and uh underwater so it doesn't
matter really if it's 20 000 feet that
the thing that's better at that point is
that you need to get there so you need
to get with all the gears with your
hiking tracking equipment High
mountaineering gears and when you get on
top of that you have to remove all that
and don't a suit
is there something uh you can speak to
the challenging aspects of that process
or is it just like this rigorous process
that's well designed you have to go
through and you don't think
this is where most of the risk is
because
you can be well prepared but for one
reason or another you get sick you know
and you can get sick not only because of
high altitude sickness it can be a
number of things or you can be tired or
you can catch a cold and then of course
you have the mountain itself
we had a magnitude 7.8 earthquake
hitting one day when we are 50 meters
away from the summit so you can't
obviously plan for that no you can't and
that's the acts of God you know uh
working with NASA uh although I am the
director of the city Institute I my
grants are coming from NASA so I'm a
NASA contractor and every time we go to
those environments we have to go through
the rigorous process of training with
NASA and checking all the boxes for
safety so they are training and training
and training us and I have to thank them
because a lot of those trainings are the
things that are in your brain when these
kind of things happen you know how to
react and you are not freaking out but
in all of the things they are training
us for you have the green risk the
yellow risk and the red risk so the
green risks are basically the don't be
stupid that don't do the kind of thing
you wouldn't be doing at home like it's
jumping you know on rocks that are not
stable you can tweak your ankle you know
and then you have other risks like high
altitude sickness how you prepare for
that how you recognize that these are
the yellow risks and then the red risk
the red bricks are what they call the
acts of gods the kind of thing that they
can happen you know there is nothing you
can do about it and then you accept that
when you do that so those are
volcanic eruptions when you're in this
kind of environment earthquakes
and everything that an Avalanches for
instance so you're in this Giant
mountain and it's shaking no it's not
shaking that's the interesting part of
it there was a whole background of
things that happened that day when we we
started off but we got to 50 meters from
the summit and I have part of my
Logistics team that is at the foot of
the mountain and being so close to the
summit we have to go under other hand of
lava so it's just like we are just under
this big Vault of lava and it's actually
beautiful if you want something
beautiful is the ultiplano scene from 20
000 feet it's just absolutely stunning
The Colors the colors are that of early
Earth which means primordial Earth it
occurs yellows oranges browns
with a dark blue sky and so you're just
you know it's a time machine you're just
out there and you're climbing 42 degree
slopes so all of a sudden I'm right next
behind the guide and the guy that's been
with us its family you know we've been
together for 10 years and he's starting
to do that
I don't discuss when Macario do that you
know I I listen and I asked the team to
do the same thing where maybe half a
dozen
and then I want to talk to him and say
what's going on is on the radio and then
he gives me the radio I'm talking to my
logistic chief officer who was at the
bottom and he said we're having a
tremendous earthquake
uh it was saying that the uh actually
the ground was waiting it was so bad
and it was freaking out because he said
everything is avalanching and I'm very
puzzled because we are in a very
dangerous part of the volcano nothing's
happening I turn around and then this is
when I realized there is just absolutely
everywhere
everything that I saw two minutes before
it's gone just disappeared into a wall
of dust but nothing's happening where we
are and uh our our friends down uh they
were freaking out because they were
seeing everything avalanching and
especially the other side of the
mountain we were on was a Vanishing so
they have no visuals they have no visual
they thought that we are caught in the
Avalanche so I said no but some uh so at
that point they thought you were screwed
yeah and I said okay so if this is
what's happening then I'm taking
everybody
to the summit because we have a very
large crater that will take care of
avalanching will be safe and I'm waiting
for the Aftershock because this is what
you do uh you know when you have
earthquakes
so here we go taking everybody in the
crater and now you have half a dozen
scientists in the crater with the Cradle
Lake and this is why we came for so we
just had a 7.8 earthquake and what do
you think they do well of course they do
the signs they came to to do so the only
thing is that I couldn't because my
radio was only working when I was on the
rim of the crater but I had a little
assistant with me a a young Bolivian
teenager had been shadowing me for three
weeks so I knew exactly what to do and
he said no you don't no problem give me
your back I'll do the sampling for you
so I was monitoring uh the situation and
I'm scared
I wasn't at that point
and
there was another moment my friend
downstairs I could you know at the foot
yeah we've known each other as I said
we're family this team is family we've
known each other I am the gunmather as
kids so we we are close
and I could feel for the first time in
in my life that he actually was scared
and he was calling me every 30 seconds
telling me stuff I said you have to stop
this now
just call me to give me information that
is useful for me to make decisions
and so
um I say okay what's going on all right
it tells me you know there is still a
balancing Etc and then a few minutes
later he calls me say I think that last
car is erupting so now I have to tell
you we are on a volcano the next volcano
we share a slope with it is a low a
little lower but that's the most
temperamental volcano of the entire
chain and this one as an history of
eruption and then my friend is telling
me that the volcano seems to be starting
to erupt if that volcano goes up we have
nowhere to go
that got my attention
so if you say scared I would say that I
got the realization that what that meant
I went called for like a fraction of a
second but that meant that just my
adrenaline started to kick in and it was
a very very strange experience because
now you have tunnel vision it's about
survival and I say okay now you are
going to tell me what I need to know you
know tell me what do you see say I see
smoke say what kind of smoke you say
it's white I say no big deal that's
water vapor okay where it's going it's
going to Argentina that was the opposite
direction where we are I said okay I'm
staying where I am because right now
there is no you know no danger
and there are still the issue of the
Aftershock
I didn't want to have the team caught in
the Gully in the central Gully of the
volcano with the Netherlands coming eras
so sit there
and he called me after that and say well
you know it's still going to Argentina
fine okay
um and then a little later he calls me
and say Natalie
um things are changing here say okay
what's going on I say well the clad is a
little yellow
and I was thinking myself yeah
what does it mean when it's yellow
sulfur and then when you have sulfur
mixed with the water vapor or the water
in your lungs this turns into sulfuric
acid
then you're really screwed
and I say okay
um where thank you for the information
where where is the club going is it the
wing is Shifting it's coming your
direction
so yeah that was a day like that you
know and I am talking to him on the
radio and I'm turning around and as I
turn around I see the cloud starting to
pop on the opposite side of the rim you
know
so at that time we had no choice anymore
because now you have to figure out
what's going to kill you first and so
there was the risk or the potential of
an avalanche
but at least you can see the rocks
the guest is going to kill you before
you can see it yeah so I called
everybody back we got our stuff
um I didn't give too much detail but I
say it's time to go
downhill and fast
so which we did we stopped only when we
were at Mid camp and then at that point
we saw the cloud just completely
covering the summit where we were so we
did well to bail out
but that was 500 meter
500 meter high over than we were so we
are safe I was just making sure that it
would not go down the slope where we
were we were safe so we stayed and you
know just rested for a little while and
after that we descended and it was all
on adrenaline I can tell you what I had
two on my crew with headaches as part of
one of them was because of the altitude
we climbed very fast the other one was
because of the cloud she was the closest
to the cloud when uh it happened so we
didn't send it fast wow that was close
that was close and it's interesting how
the human body and mind works because I
know that from the moment my friend told
me that the volcano seemed to be
erupting I was going on adrenaline
but when we got close to them and I saw
him we are getting close to the cars I
saw him come in towards me and the slope
all of a sudden all the adrenaline went
away
I was a mess I had to find the first
rock and sit down yeah it was gone I
mean fascinating so you just basically
physically mentally collapsed once you
saw so there's nothing left of me I got
in the car and I felt in the cars we
were heading back towards a camp I could
have passed out I really fought back and
I'm not the kind of passing out really
you know easy but there was nothing left
I had no energy no nothing
it's fabulous how you react and how this
is embedded in your brain from and of
evolution of reaction to a dangerous
situation basically
the drive to survive yeah something like
that you just told us one heck of a
story and as you said such story comes
along with many
of the diving Expeditions that you do
but on the science side
what is that world that simulates that
travels back in time into the Martian
landscape what is the science reveal
so the science reveals that
I feel resilient when I started that
project I told my husband I said this is
going to be very fast we are going in
such nasty environment that we're not
going to find anything and you know
world back home uh fairly soon
so 20 years later we are still studying
those environments that was a gut
feeling like nothing not much can
possibly survive well the the UV
environment is so nasty but there you
find the same microorganism that made
the very first fossils on Earth 3.5
billion years ago
and they keep surviving they developed
an adaptation
Swiss armina if you prefer
and so you learn about that you learn
about what they are how they adapt
through times and through environmental
changes which is really important what
are their signatures we learn to
recognize them we learn what kind of
instrument we need what kind of of
signature whether it's chemical or
morphological or whatnot so basically we
learn how to explore but I would say
that to me and this is a realization
interestingly enough that came three
years into the project
uh I really woke up literally one
morning saying you know we have been
coming here for three years now try and
understand how to search for Life on
Mars but what this place is showing us
is what's happening right here right now
on our own planet
and uh by exploring those extreme
environments we are also reaching to
places not too many people go and so
we're learning more about our own
biospheres and uh the diversity of our
own life here on Earth so these are the
two main things you know that I would
say what kind of life
survives up there
well there's volcanoes it's about
bacteria you know mostly is there
something
specific about that bacteria that's able
to be so rugged yes
um they have adapted to very high UV
radiation and it's not only because they
are at high altitude it's because early
Earth
didn't have an ozone layer so when those
the ancestors of those bacteria
originated they have to survive a world
where you had lots of short UV coming
down at the surface and also lots of
hydrothermal environments you know
volcanoes and hot water lots of salt and
you see all these toolbox
Steel
embedded in those microorganisms today 4
billion years later it's just amazing
and depending on the environment they
are going to switch some of these
defenses adaptation on or off
the UV
situation there is so nasty that
here you have bacterias like that
cyanobacteria you find them everywhere
it's really something you find all over
the place but if you find them here in
California they will turn their
protection against UV during the day in
summer and they will switch it off at
the end of the day
there in the Andes it's so nasty is that
that thing stays on all the time
but if you take samples and bring them
back here and start to
culture them like we did on top of a
building leaving them you know you will
see the second generation of this
organism they are starting to switch on
and off again
so they're extremely adaptable extremely
rugged and that's why they are still
here
and probably that's why we are here
because life found sways so is there
some degree to which the harshness of
the conditions
enables
flourishing of life versus shuts it down
well it will shut down
those that cannot survive obviously you
know this is a statement that's Captain
Obvious right there but it's also
the survival of the fittest and this is
what evolution is all right
so they are here because they were the
most deductible
and so
evolution is going to show the path of
the fittest the one that cannot resist
they might have a good time for a little
while but then you know we've seen this
at much different scale and with complex
life not so long ago a hundred thousand
years ago meanderthal
was side by side by Homo sapiens but
nandatho was completely adapted to a
cold Earth to a glacial Earth of the end
of the pleistocene
and when condition change
it couldn't last you think I mean
there's still some Mysteries around that
right like exactly exactly what were the
harshness of the conditions
um I still really suspicious what did
Homo sapiens do no no no I really want
to know no no I I'm Shady stuff that
happened yeah shitty stuff happened they
met they bred together they fought
against each other
what humans do you had to expect that
but the thing is that Neanderthal was
completely adapted for a very long time
to leave at the edge of those glaciers
there were probably in a weekend
situation when Homo sapiens came uh and
and started to spread so
um basically this is what life does it
adapts and if you cannot add apps
anymore it disappear and something else
takes over thank you
hold the women's world record for diving
at altitudes both scuba and freediving
so I have to ask what can you describe
the details of those records I never
looked for those I I'm not after records
at all in fact I didn't know I had
broken those records when that happened
um we did that as part of our Expedition
our scientific Expedition so it's
basically sport in the name of science
versus no it's science in the name of
Science and it's just a very physical
thing that you have to do so we train
ourselves like athletes yeah but to get
the job done to get the job done you're
holding your breath underwater for a
very long time like with free diving
what what are we talking about do you do
you think in terms of time is there like
layers where you know through training
you're in a good place like I'm sure you
take time off and you get rusty right I
and I had I have not been diving in a
while so probably I need to go back to
you know the drawing board and at the
bottom of the swimming pool but having
training from the past I think you know
it will pick up much more faster than
um basically I would never have those
altitude that would never go over three
minutes that would be suicidal so the
altitude is much tougher than the pool
back at ground level
it is but it's because when you come up
yeah that's not the going in the water
when I'm on the water I'm fine and if I
wanted I could stay longer but it
wouldn't be very wise
uh you've written about the history of
Life on Mars like you said you've kind
of exploring that by looking at the
Lakes here
um do you think there's been Life on
Mars do you think there is life on Mars
right so when you're looking at the
environment of Mars early on it's fairly
similar to that of early Earth never was
exactly the same because Mars was always
father from the Sun uh than the earth
right so it was always a little cooler
but you have to imagine maybe the Arctic
during the summer that would be early
Mars with a lot going on for it in terms
of environment very favorable to even
Life as we know it so
we don't know how fast life
happen on Earth they are signs right now
showing that it might have actually
originated only 200 million years after
the crust cooled down yeah uh this still
has to be verified but that that's the
closest and these are indirect evidence
like
carbon left by the activity of life not
life itself and there is a Twist in the
story for Mars is that it seems that
Mars came together as a planet faster
than the earth and had water earlier
than the earth
so it may be that Mars was habitable and
might have seen the beginning of Life
earlier than the Earth
so all of this is speculation obviously
we haven't found any evidence or solid
evidence yet I would say unambiguous
evidence but unambiguous evidence of
life is going to be something uh
interesting to prove because we don't
know what life is remember so I always
joke that the only way we would know
that there is life on Mars if there was
a rabbit jumping in front of the of the
Rover but we might be you know Gathering
we have what we call a ladder of Life
detection which is that you have a
series of uh rungs that you know you
need to go through
that actually are not proving you that
you've discovered life but are making
um the possibility that what you
discovered was made only by the
environment more and more and probable
so we are trying to prove the contrary
right so this is what we have right now
and as far as I'm concerned
continuing all the unknowns we have I
think there was as much chance that life
originated on Mars that they did on
Earth and
um if it was at the surface then it got
in trouble after 500 million years
because of The Disappearance of the
magnetosphere the loss of the
magnetosphere and the atmosphere but as
we know you know life doesn't only
stay in one place as soon as it's out
there it's going to adapt it's going to
give itself more chance
to survive and that to me means that if
life appeared I would say
it's still there and probably on the
ground where it can be you know in an
environment that's more stable so I
don't know how stability is good or not
it might not be so good but they might
be in a different type of metabolism
through dormancy you know waiting for
different climate cycles and there is
the fact that Mars changes but it's
faster
than the earth and climate changes are a
lot stronger in magnitude so there might
be a place on Mars we know that there is
a place on Mars deeper in the subsurface
where temperature and pressure are good
for liquid water to stay there so these
would be good places for a stable
habitat over time no matter what happens
at the surface
but if uh life is also caught
between that deep Zone and the surface
there is an active layer there is a lot
of ice in the subsurface of Mars and
when the climate changes when the
obliquity goes beyond 30 degrees then at
that point you will have some activation
of that zone you have following of the
eyes so all this region is reactivated
and maybe that's a way where you have
Pathways for life to move from the deep
Zone to closer to the surface this is
why I am one of those scientists who
thinks that life might not be so far
from the surface than we think
so we don't have to dig very far to find
it we probably won't and the reason I'm
not so amazing I I'm thinking of that
just because of this experience as well
of extreme environments you know you
have to sit and look and listen
basically the story of my life if I want
to understand where microbes are located
on Mars I have to become the microbe
right this is the thought experiment and
if I want to understand where ET is yeah
then I have to become ET so it's a big
stretch but in extreme environment you
sit in the desert for a while and you
just you know try to understand
where the wind's coming from where the
humidity when it's showing up and then
you start to understand the patterns of
those things what are the useful signals
that you need for survival you need to
know where water is where the source of
energy is going to be uh drawn from you
need to find shelters and shelters don't
mean that for instance you can have a
water column of a lake or a river or
whatnot or the ocean it can be also a
very thin layer of dust or it can be a
translucent Rock
and you see what we call endless these
are the same cyanobacteria but the
different version of them they live
inside the Rocks inside those crystals
because they have the best of Life they
are into translucent crystals so that
they receive the light from the sun they
can do the photosynthesis
but there is enough of that Crystal so
that the nasty UV is being stopped
and they are in their little house
and um when you are looking at the
temperature within those rocks they tend
to make it toastier than the outside
temperature so there is a lot of thing
going on
um so what I'm saying for Mars is that
yeah right now you don't have an
atmosphere very much 160 times thinner
than the earth six midi bar is really
not much but it's there
um but you still have a lot of UV the
short UV like the nasty one UVA UVB UVC
that can really mess up your DNA uh and
and destroy it Beyond repair
but as soon as you have a little alcove
into a rock or a cliff
you know
I'd be looking at those places but you
have to understand Mars or any other
planet for that matter at the level that
matters for the microbe
and is so then maybe one with the
microbe one with the microbes which
means that we have lots of orbital data
which is good to understand habitability
at the planet level or at the regional
level
but we have very little data right now
that is very useful to understand
habitability
uh at the scale that matters for the
microbes at this point in time so we
need to uh to do a better job with that
my ideas uh is to you know have arrays
of environmental station that could have
a lot of benefits one would be to give
us that Vision at for the microbes that
would be good for us through biology
and second a collection of stations on
Mars on Mars yeah that give us a good
map yeah high resolution we can do that
originally and on top of that so that's
good for us through biology for the
search for Life on Mars that's good
about how to learn where microbes could
be that can be a problem for
contamination both ways so that's good
for planetary protection and since those
stations would have communication
capabilities on them that excellent for
human exploration because normally you
have weather stations all over the place
that can tell your astronauts you know
learn the pattern when it's a good time
to go out or not go out and also house
and communicate uh when they they go and
do sorties so there are a number of
things we can do that can tell you lots
of information that's rewind the clock a
little bit you grew up in Paris
I was just there Helen McDonald in her
New York Times amazing profile piece of
you writes to your teenage years were
troubled
so how did the challenging early years
make the human being the scientist they
are today
everything I think that
um
this is what's taking me on top of those
big mountains
and the irony is for me to be looking
for the origin and nature of life
because I was so close to losing it but
to me that was a great lesson learned
and that helped me see through the
beauty of life
and going on the other side of that it
became really what made me and helped me
go through absolutely everything and
anything in life
climb mountains and tell me there is
something I want to know and and you
know
um
I am going to give it my best and I
won't give up and I won't give in and
this is a message that I carried all my
life and I'm so very grateful that I did
because all these things that I would
have missed if I hadn't done that you
know this is something that I wrote in
my first book and part of it is the
reason why I wrote it just because I
felt that there were messages in in my
path
um oftentimes teenagers are troubled it
can be one way or another or if it's not
a troubled teenage you have times in
your life where you doubt where you know
you're just within your home and say
what's the purpose what's the reason why
carrying on and when I see all the
things that I'm doing the dream that I
was able to fulfill
what a waste it would have been you know
so there's in there was a point in your
life where you thought about suicide oh
yeah yeah and I did more than thinking
about it and but I was a direct one for
some reason I'm still here I still don't
know why but I'm still here and the
lesson for me was that never ever again
because you have to give tomorrow a
chance you never can think about
tomorrow in the terms of the present you
never know what can happen you know what
is going to happen if you go
through
what you want to do tomorrow is never
happening you know and I had I had a the
other lesson came a few years later
where actually somebody was drowning and
I went after that person I almost died
that day too not that I wanted to but
it's just because the conditions were
very very difficult
that person died from there although we
we took him out of the water but I had a
a lot of difficulty coming out I came
out but then I thought a lot about that
guy he was in his 30s and it was like a
sort of a echo from a few years before
telling me that person would never have
tomorrow that person would never be able
to fulfill his dream or even have dreams
of any kind
and I was here and I was going to give
myself the best chance to fulfill all
the dreams I wanted to and go after all
the questions I wanted to and this is
what kept me going now you know so the
advice there is even if you don't see a
why
an answer to the why question why I live
uh today
give tomorrow a chance always
do you think about your
death today do you think about your
mortality
not really you've been so close to this
to me yeah yeah we know that's part of
life and you know what if something
happens to me what I'm doing the stuff I
love
what a way of going
this will happen wherever it catches me
I don't know I don't care it will be
what it will be and I had the best of
all Masters for that
I had my husband my husband and I were
44 years apart in age
and it was just a Pure Love Story
and it never looked at his age never
thought about himself
or Define himself by his age in fact he
reinvented the life for himself at an
age where everybody retires we met when
he was 66. and that was a blessing and a
curse but a blessing most of it because
we took every single day as if it was
the last so we enjoyed life
and right now
it's not so much you know I have to
really think of him it just passed away
this August last August
and and for me it's more like I have to
draw from his example
on him always telling me
look forward
trust life
be happy
live
you know today every single day I have
to remind several times a day of this
it's not easy but he had the recipe he
never thought about death because when
you start thinking too much about that
that prevents you from living
foreign
oh gosh we were so close I think we were
it's more like
one spirit and two bodies we were that
close so missing him doesn't even cut it
I mean it's
it's the toughest Mountain I ever
climbed
what's the role of Love In The Human
Condition
I think I hope
that this is the force that drives the
universe although you know we might be
experiencing the other side of it maybe
just to learn how important love is that
might be it you know
um for me
and my experience with my husband where
I never had to wake up every single
morning ever wondering if I was loved I
had to look in his eyes
and limb looking back at me to know it
you know so when you get to that point
where you don't question it anymore I
would hope for Humanity to reach that
point where you can feel the same love
for the person that is unknown in the
street
that you feel for the people you love I
think that at that point we are going to
be reaching the maturity of that
Civilization we are hoping for and
seeing the universe through love
uh
that doesn't run spacecrafts of course
but
putting love into our intent of going
into and settling into another planet
instead of oh my God we need to escape
because we are freaking uh messing up
with our own Planet
I think that this is the answer to so
many things
foreign
is there a part of you
that maybe just a little bit
wants to step foot on Mars like you
personally oh yeah of course I'm curious
I'm a scientist and I've been working on
on Mars I I was actually privileged to
be working on Yusuf Creator and deciding
for the landing side of the spirit rover
which means that I worked on on that
Landing site for 15 years and I got to
see it from the ground that's the
closest you know to being there and
exploring of course that's not
physically be present there
um if you were giving me the opportunity
of course I would go but I know one
thing
I would want to come back
so given the option
of dying on Mars
or dying on Earth you'd visit Mars but
you would like to spend your last days
here yeah because of a number of things
I think that
first we are not ready to sit on Mars
regardless of what being said it's it
will happen it will happen and because
we are explorers humans you know they're
Explorers so this will happen and it's a
good thing depending on how we go about
this it can be a very good thing
we're not waste time as much has been
exploring continue to explore the big
questions of origin and nature of life
or exploring of a planet
the love you are talking about love the
love for my own planet
has grown deeper
and my concern about it has grown deeper
so the data that I'm collecting to learn
about other planets I'm also using it to
understand better our home planet and
trying to make it a little better for
the next Generation so
um if you were talking about love this
is love that would drive me back here
yeah this planet
is just sometimes I just pause and I'm
in awe the incredible thing we have here
and just and I have deep gratitude for
all the life forms here
the the beautiful complexity of course
this Darkness behind it all the Death
all the extinction that led uh up to us
to descendants of Vape sitting here
today I feel that's a responsibility
were the fittest that survived exactly
right as the
dominant species at least you know
technologically
Etc maybe not the wisest one but the
dominant species we have a
responsibility towards the entire
biosphere because the decisions we are
making now
normally affect us they are affecting
the entire biosphere and right now the
choices we are making are leading to The
Disappearance of 150 species every
single day
all the big mammals on this Earth
today are on the brick of Extinction
we are within the six
greatest Max Extinction it's unfolding
before our eyes and
um I would strongly suggest that we use
our smart
to help a little bit this situation and
we can do this I think we can do this we
just need to
redirect our energy
in the Name of Love
this was an incredible conversation I'm
really honored that you sit with me
um I've been a fan of your work for a
long time now so this is this is really
awesome thank you so much for talking
you're very welcome thanks
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Natalie Cabral to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
stanislav Lam and Solaris
how do you expect to communicate with
the ocean when we can't even understand
one another
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time